do you think a kid growing up right now
with technology has the possibility of
being as skilled as you are at
communicating if they're spending much
more of their time like this I do I get
where that's coming from and I see the
anxiety that our kids are less social
this that the amount of charismatic 14
year olds that I even see here let alone
know it's very high sure kids are in
their phone and iPads more than they
were 30 years ago because we didn't have
that but I played Nintendo for nine
hours a day during the summer and watch
Saved by the Bell you know what I mean
like it's not like I was at 14 running
around at right mixers and cocktail
parties I was definitely an 80s kid that
was outside a lot but you know my
brother wasn't that I see plenty of
social skills in him